just ignore Ukraine in the Russian ruble
how do you bring that into your mix as
you start the week I'd say I ignore
Ukraine because I think it's much more
geopolitical than financial the Louvre
although is is you know something you
would keep an eye on because you know it
is tied to kind of what's going on in
oil more more I think than what's
happening in Ukraine and it does have
some spillover effects into places like
the Turkish lira seems to be pretty
correlated with the with the Google
right now the gold is up you like gold
is it up up like a new gold market or
are you just making it almost a trade
from 1100 up to something no I I think
about that bear market sort of hung
around with us for three and a half
years did a lot of damage to people and
you know it might really be over I mean
certainly in nine US dollars gold looks
to be back in a genuine bull market you
know one of the things we're all
struggling to wrap our heads around are
these negative yields were seen coming
out of Europe what are the consequences
of that for your strategy well I think
it makes gold more attractive in it was
I mean the opportunity cost of owning it
is basically is basically zero I mean it
doesn't really the negative yields don't
basically affect us fortunately we're
not managing money in Europe where we
have those kinds of positions you know
i'm not sure what it really means longer
term for financial markets one of the
but i do think one of the consequences
is that central banks now hate cash for
set the central bank's feel a political
need to actually earn a return on their
nations on their nation's capital and i
think one of the reasons why bond yields
are where they are is the amount of
central bank money and solve and wealth
money which is poured into fixed so
don't open the floodgates of money
flowing into US Treasuries i'm looking
at your research note from last week for
market filled and I noticed that you
pointed out that central banks are no
longer concerned about volatility they
don't really see that as part of their
mission should they have ever seen it as
part of their mission to worry about
volatility well I think when you have
the kind of volatility you had in 2008
yes and again in a knock-on effect in
2011 but I think they were a little bit
too far down that road i mean i think
that the central bank started not caring
what markets did in the summer of 2008
and founding out but it mattered a great
deal for the real economy you went
through something similar in 2011 and
then i think they stayed a little bit
too too long on that horse and i think
we've got off it now but you don't want
central bank governors that are beholden
to the
mark you want them to be pursuing the
dual mandate of employment inflation yes
but I think they understood that if they
allow the bond equity commodities and
everything else to go to hell in a
handbasket in late 2008 there was gonna
be no alignment what does a lousy
January signal to you or is it swarthy
into februari anywhere to January go and
it was like negative three percent
whatever does that mean is that anything
cosmic to Michael sure no but I think it
does tell you the enthusiasm got a
little bit ahead of itself by the end of
last year it doesn't necessarily tell us
what happens in the next 11 months of
the year but I think by the end of
December you know for the first time in
many years i think that the average
investors enthusiasm was ahead of
reality in this market do you see this
rally that with it has been happening in
the u.s. continuing yes but i think well
i mean if you don't have a one from 2009
yes but with a lot more volatility
attached a lot more meaning is that mean
is there is there a trading strategy
around that I mean or is it just
unpredictable volatility well respond
would call it stochastic well I think
you'll see concerns build around I think
you'll see concerns build around certain
ideas whether it's lower energy prices
being a problem or a stronger dollar
being a problem or I think later this
year the Federal Reserve being a
problematic you know I think you'll go
through periods in which the market
really gets concerned about way to
explain that later this year the Federal
Reserve being a problem I think if we
assume that the Fed is still on track to
raise rates in the middle of vicia vatel
give a market something else to worry
about what a debate James Bullard in
Mohamed el-erian flat-out disagreeing on
this on Friday let's have you clear the
area mr. Bullard was hugely respectful
of what markets are saying about dis
inflation Mohamed el-erian said a lot to
do with structural oil moves which is
when when you see dis inflation signaled
by five year five your brakes or
whatever what does that signal the Janet
Yellen no I think the whole bond markets
crazy right now it's taken a break of
following economic data I think there is
no sign of CPI but I I wouldn't look at
inflation expectations of the bond
market and say that it tells me anything
about it economy